most other sites have dropped for at
least a week
most are down sharply or are fluctuating
at levels well below their ba1 peaks
edmonton and lethbridge in particular
are down to a fraction of their ba wine
banks
edmonton has been dropping for two
waiting at levels well below their ba1
peaks
edmonton and lethbridge in particular
are down to a fraction of their ba1
peaks
edmonton has been dropping for two weeks
from a recent peak april 18th to the
latest update for may the second
lethbridge has dropped for a week from
its recent peak of april the 20th
this is good news but let's be clear
what it means and not and and what it
does not mean
it looks like we're passing the peak of
ba2 circulation with less impact than we
saw with ba1 thanks to vaccine and prior
exposure
but
hospital admissions are still rising and
they'll continue to rise for a few more
weeks even assuming virus levels
continue to decline
over the past week we've seen another
small increase in covet positive
patients in hospitals while the number
in intensive care has remained about the
same for the past month
our data is in line with what we're
seeing in other provinces it looks like
ba1 or sorry ba2 has peaked in quebec
and ontario as both provinces are
recording declining rates of
transmissions and new cases
in bc they're continuing to see a rise
in new cases and admissions to hospital
but it's much slower
than compared to the ba1 wave that we
had last late last year
so it's becoming clear that we and other
provinces are seeing less impact from
ba2
that's a in line with what we expected
and we hope it will be the pattern with
future waves
but we don't know that
future variants could have more impact
so we need to plan for future waves and
press ahead with the work underway to
add capacity and we're doing that right
across the system from ems to surgery to
continuing care
and the reality is our hospitals and the
system overall remains under significant
stress
we're seeing the equivalent of yet
another winter peak in patient volumes
especially in ems and in emergency
departments
the numbers overall remain in line with
past years but occupancy at a few large
sites is well over 100 percent and while
some periods of very high occupancy are
normal this is not a normal year after
two years of coven 19.
the staff are under real strain and we
owe them a tremendous debt of gratitude
i hope and expect they'll start to see
some relief soon as a level of virus
drops and once again to all of them i
would like to say thank you
once the levels drop that will mean
fewer patients needing admission as well
as fewer blocked beds due to infection
control measures and fewer staff off
sick or in isolation
the healthcare workforce has been
strained by the pandemic in alberta and
in every province and we need to build
it up so we are doing that adding nurses
paramedics and other staff as fast as we
can recruit them
we need to live with kovid at the same
time that we manage all the other
pressures on the system and the key to
living with covid is getting more people
vaccinated
we're grateful to each and every
albertan who has been vaccinated with
all the doses they are eligible for
at the same time we continue to use any
tool available
to protect people and reduce the strain
on our hospitals
one of those tools is the antiviral drug
paxlovid
as i mentioned last week we've been
working to transition the prescribing
process to family physicians and other
primary care providers
today i am pleased to announced two
changes
first starting today albertans who meet
the clinical criteria for paxlovid can
be assessed for treatment and obtained a
prescription directly from a physician
nurse practitioner or pharmacist
this change will make it faster and
easier to access the drug and begin
treatment which must be started within
five days of the onset of symptoms that
said prescribers are still getting the
tools and supports they need to make
sure they're comfortable prescribing pax
love it so we don't expect that all
service providers will start this right
away
eligible albertans can still call ahs if
that's more convenient or if their
primary care practitioner is not
prescribing at this time or they don't
have a family position or can't get in
to see one right away
we're also making the testing
requirements more flexible
as you know up until now eligible
individuals have needed a positive coven
19 test result in order to get a
prescription
effective immediately a posit positive
rapid test result will be accepted as
well
it can be a test done at home and then
confirmed by a prescriber
or one that a prescriber administers in
their own clinic
which type of test and where it's
administered will be at the description
of the prescriber
albertan's at high risk of severe
outcomes who know or suspect they're
positive for coven 19 should call their
physician
nurse practitioner or pharmacist to
determine if they're eligible for
treatment the testing requirements and
whether prescribing is offered
we're making these changes to help more
albertans access paxlovit but a reminder
the clinical criteria are based on
expert judgment of the risks and
benefits of the drug they're based on
the evidence and those criteria remain
in place
primary care providers can align covet
19 treatments with their patients health
status and goals and serve them in their
own communities to date more than 1700
prescriptions for paxlovit have been
written we have more than 29 000 courses
of treatment in stock
so don't hesitate to pursue this
treatment option if you or someone you
know may be eligible
call your physician's office
pharmacy or health link as soon as
symptoms development as i said before
while paxlovid can help it's not a
replacement for vaccination
if you haven't yet received every dose
you're eligible for please do not wait
once again thank you for doing
everything that you do and thanks again
to all
of our healthcare workforce for stepping
up during these challenging times and
with that i now invite dr hinshaw to
give her update
thank you minister and good afternoon
everyone while our efforts have largely
been focused on covert 19 in the past
few years
my team continues to work on other
issues impacting the health of albertans
so i would like to start today by
talking briefly about avian influenza
and human health implications
avian influenza is a disease that occurs
naturally among wild aquatic birds
and it can spread to domestic poultry as
well as other birds and animals
currently there are several farms in
alberta with the virus in their flocks
and some wild birds in the province in
whom the virus has been found
our colleagues at alberta agriculture
and alberta environment are working
closely with the canadian food
inspection agency to manage the animal
health implications
but i know albertans involved with these
farms or living in these communities may
have questions on what this means for
their personal health
what is most important to know is that
there have been no cases in people in
alberta and it is very rare for people
to be infected with avian influenza
there is currently one case under
investigation in the united states
however this involves an individual who
had very close contact with infected
poultry this week alberta health
services public health nurses will be
calling impacted farmers to discuss
human health implications
and ways to keep their families workers
and other people on the farms healthy
we've also received questions on whether
it is safe to consume poultry or poultry
products such as eggs particularly from
hunters or individuals with small
backyard flocks
this food is safe to eat if properly
cooked
avian influenza virus is destroyed at
the temperatures required to cook meat
or eggs as would routinely be done
i encourage albertans to visit
alberta.ca if they have any other
questions about avian influenza
alberta health has information related
to public health and both agriculture
and environment have information related
to animal health available
for anyone with a small backyard poultry
flock if you have not already signed up
with alberta agriculture to receive
information that may be relevant to you
and your flock you can do so on their
website
a more common risk that i also want to
highlight today is seasonal influenza
we are experiencing a rise in seasonal
influenza with levels higher than they
have been at any time in the past two
years
in alberta we have had more than 700
cases diagnosed this season with a vast
majority identified in the past two
months of these 68 people have needed
hospital care and three have needed care
in the icu
actions to lower the risk of influenza
infection are the same as those we need
to continue for covid
washing our hands regularly staying home
if sick and for those at higher risk of
severe outcomes considering actions like
wearing masks when in public places
turning to today's covid19 update
between tuesday april 26th and monday
may 2nd our pcr test positivity ranged
from 21 to 27.3 percent with an average
of 23 percent for the week
this is a slight decrease from the
previous week
as the minister mentioned
hospitalizations have increased slightly
from last week and currently there are
1267 people with coveton hospital
including 46 in the icu
sadly between april 26th and may 2nd 69
deaths related to covet 19 were reported
to alberta health with an average of
approximately 10 per day
the individuals whose deaths were
reported over the past week were between
the ages of 28
and 102
my thoughts are with every albertan
grieving the loss of someone they cared
about no matter the cause
whether we're grieving the loss of a
loved one experiencing illness ourselves
or adjusting to transition to a more
normal life the last few years have
taken a toll on all of us
so as this week is mental health week i
would like to recognize the complex
emotions many of us are feeling right
now and the fact that albertans continue
to wrestle with the effects of this
pandemic in many ways
depression and anxiety in us or those we
care about
are just some of the ways these impacts
can show up
if you or someone you know is having
these struggles or if dealing with
stress or uncertainty feels overwhelming
or is interfering with daily life i urge
you to seek support
free non-judgmental help is available
for anyone who needs it
a list of comprehensive resources is
available at alberta.ca
mental health
albertans can also call 211 anytime day
or night
for mental health support
and no matter what you're struggling
with
i want you to know you are not alone
it takes courage to reach out for help
and that help is there for you
i'd like to end today by encouraging
each of us to find ways this week to
employ compassion
both for ourselves and those around us
that could include practicing self-care
strategies such as exercise eating well
or using mindfulness techniques
it could also mean reaching out to a
loved one or someone in the community to
see how they're doing
we need each other as we always have
and making time to show we care can have
positive impacts far beyond a single
moment
there are a lot of challenges that face
us and all of them are easier to manage
when we work on them together
thank you and we're happy to take
questions
thanks dr hinshaw and minister looks
like just two reporters in the queue on
the phone and no one here in the room so
we'll take the first caller please
operator
adam toy global
yes thanks for taking my question um we
saw this week
lineups out of the alberta children's
hospital emergency department doors in
calgary here this week um hs uh we're
still waiting for a response from from
them but a question for the health
minister wondering if if you're aware of
this uh if you're aware of anything that
might be behind this
for example uh for example any sort of
staffing issues at ach and uh if so
what's being addressed what's being done
to address it
so thanks for the question so i'm not
aware of any staffing issues report the
the initial report that i got back there
is no staffing issues currently uh the
volumes are high i had an opportunity to
uh tour the royal alex uh earlier this
week
and uh you know and had this
conversation about volumes and what's
driving it and it's a combination of
factors um one of the factors uh is
associated with with uh covid uh ba2
obviously uh but as mentioned by dr
hinshaw the flu is impacting it and
there's also higher levels of acuity one
of the things that doctors were
commenting and that they're seeing is
that um
individuals who you know
during the two years of covert
previously
did not see as much in terms of the
primary care so they're presented to the
hospital with higher levels of levels of
acuity so all of these things are are
driving um sort of higher volumes right
at this point in time um and the
solution quite frankly for that is is
you know increasing capacity as i
mentioned earlier today we're doing that
that's going to take time but i do want
to thank again all of our health care
providers to suspend this work that
they're doing in terms of managing
through this volume um you know very
hopeful that you know we're seeing signs
of
declining in terms of community spread
uh we'll still see
increased pressure on our system over
the next few weeks as it works its way
through but then to be able to come back
and then we can focus on uh on
on adding more capacity for future
rounds and you'll see that pressure come
down
thanks minister adam a follow up
yes a question for dr hinshaw
a children's hospital yard doc we spoke
with says the flu and covet are both
peaking at the same time
what can be done about this should kids
be wearing masks can there be an
increased push for vaccinations
we know that
the influenza a
virus that's currently circulating
is
one that's not ideally matched to the
vaccine that that was used this season
so when that happens while vaccine can
still help somewhat
we know that in the past the
effectiveness of influenza vaccine kind
of ranges year to year
what i would say with respect to the
things that are most important to
manage or lower the risk for both
influenza and kovid whether it's for
kids or people of any other age
is
again making sure that hands are washed
regularly certainly masks are an
important intervention and especially
for those who have risk factors wearing
masks in public places is an important
consideration
also making sure that
we continue to normalize in all of our
circles
the important habit of staying home when
sick so
trying to avoid uh being around people
who have a respiratory illness
and making sure that
we're supporting those who who need
perhaps a little bit of time
if they're feeling sick to to not be in
close proximity to others so those are
really the key things obviously covid
vaccination is highly effective at
preventing severe outcomes so that's an
important intervention for children who
are old enough to receive that
and for younger children again it really
is about those other key preventive
measures that people can take every day
thanks dr hinshaw we'll go to the next
caller please
terry ctv
hi there uh i just have a quick question
about the situation in calgary in terms
of the wastewater to the minister or dr
hinshaw i know that we're saying in
other areas that declining what is the
situation like in calgary is it you know
staying the same or increasing and just
what kind of concerning levels are those
at any kind of reminders to calgarians
or anything of that note
i'll maybe start and and then if the
minister wants to add uh that would be
great so
we are seeing uh you have seen
throughout the last month or so higher
levels in calgary with respect to virus
and wastewater
we know that that's a marker of
transmission in the community that
doesn't rely on test seeking behaviors
but
we are you know again seeing that in
most other places in the province that
decline from a previous peak we expect
that in calgary
we would start to see that as well we
know our other leading indicator of test
positivity is beginning to decline and
so
ultimately i think the the
important thing for albertans to be able
to do when they're wondering about risk
in their own community is to look at the
information that's available on the
alberta health website
where they can see multiple indicators
including the cases that have been
diagnosed in the last week in in their
geographic area they can see the
positivity rates in different zones and
they can see the wastewater results for
different cities where that's being
tracked and use that as a measure of
what the risk might be in those
communities to inform the decisions that
they make about their daily activities
thanks dr hinshaw terry follow-up
yeah just on that note i should have
asked at the beginning but um is there
any uh indication why calgary's kind of
bucking the trend
it's really difficult to say one of the
things that's important to
remember about wastewater again is that
the absolute level is difficult to
compare from one city to another just
because there's some different sampling
techniques so while we're working on
variation uh reducing variation across
the province what is most important is
to look at the the trends in any given
area so it's really difficult to say why
calgary might be a little bit different
why they might
not be coming down as as quickly as
other places but ultimately whatever the
the reasons for that change in the or
the difference in the trend again the
important thing is to use that as one of
several metrics when people are looking
at what their risks might be in their
community to inform those uh protective
actions that they take
thanks dr hinshaw we started with two
but i think one more joint so operator
we'll take a third call and then stop
there
laura beamish fort mac today
thank you so much for taking my question
minister copping um it's unrelated to
covid but back in 2018 it was reported
the ndp government was discussing
expanding abortion services to fort
mcmurray left bridge medicine hat grand
prairie and red beer obviously kovid 19
has had a great impact since then but is
pursuing this a priority
so so my understanding um when uh my
predecessor was asked the same question
and looked into that is that
you know even though the previous
government may have spoken to that issue
you know ahs is the one that that makes
the decisions of what services will be
provided and where based on the demand
and they had no plans to be able to uh
they had no plans to increase the
uh the current level of service that
abortions are provided and as you know
abortions are provided in uh you know
those clinics in uh in calgary and
edmonton uh my understanding is hs has
no current plans to uh to expand that
but there you know also is you know
other options uh associated with uh
um
uh
uh
uh
sorry uh
uh mifo j
jimiso um which is a which is an oral
based option that is available across
the province
thanks minister laura follow up
yeah thank you minister cupping just
when you're looking at expanding and
increasing more health care support in
rural areas
isn't abortion services something that
you're talking about or looking at
so so again ahs is you know when we look
at services generally um you look at the
demand that and the requirement and then
ahs looks at that with the demand where
it's needed and how and they do that not
with just abortion they do that with
with all services um so you know uh
transfusion services for example you
know cardiac services so there is an
assessment that they actually go through
um you know one of our focuses um in the
challenges that we're having right now
is about ensuring that we have the staff
in rural alberta to be able to deliver
the services that ahs has already
determined that that should be delivered
giving the demographics and the demand
in those locations
and so we are focused on on increasing
increasing staff recruitment and
retention of doctors and other
healthcare professionals and rural
alberta to be able to deliver those
services that have already been
determined that that are are required uh
given the demographics and given the
demand
thanks minister uh and thanks dr hinshaw
uh we'll stop there and see you back
here next week for the next update
thank you